[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice you can use in your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
stoic practices from epictetuses and
caridian and
that might sound like a little bit of a
mouthful so we probably have a little
bit of explaining to do at the top of
this show you know i think we should
probably spend a little bit of time dan
and i are both members of the milwaukee
stoic fellowship so we can tell you
about what what stoicism
is and then we have to tell you a little
bit about this epictetus guy why we're
talking about him you know what's so
important and then you know we already
got another technical term in there and
caribbean what what's that so we got a
little bit of
stuff ahead of us but we've got some
really cool practices that you can use
to start improving
your life and we're going to spend
almost the entire session
outlining these talking about how you
would understand them and apply them
so let's start at the start dan what's
stoicism
stoicism is a
philosophy usually referred to as a
philosophy of life in which it uh is a
practice philosophy so it incorporates
both ethics as well as logic and if you
want to go back to the ancients includes
like physics which would consider like
if you want to use the
the modern term for that be like both uh
science but also like ontology or like
the
what is in everything but um
uh once again it's it's an ancient
philosophy founded in athens by
xenocidium
um
and it is kind of an amalgamation of a
couple of other um
philosophies i'm still in the uh
the lineage of you know following
socrates um and uh has little bits of
you know
the um
cynics the magathians and the um
the
academics yeah exactly and so yeah they
kind of got the triple whammy right they
got three different uh strains flowing
in
so that's good
and and the handbook or the anki rydian
as we are calling it is um
the the piece of a
work that we have that is the distilled
teachings of epictetus
but they're not written by epictetus
they are written by one of his students
this guy named
aaron um and so uh you know can we go
through the the etymology of uh the uh
anti-written in here yeah so it's um
basically three things that there's the
n in right and then
is hand in in classic greek um so in
your hand and then the idiom is just a
diminutive so the little thing that goes
in your hand and by the way epictetus
isn't the only person to write something
that's called the n caridian um
augustine of hippo would later write an
end creating and there's quite a few
other authors and it's the same basic
idea it's sort of like
what you can
i mean you know how we we used to have
these these
paperbacks you could buy all over the
place and you could stick them in your
back pocket so you could you know go
read your book wherever you wanted to
this is kind of like that except you
know i don't know that they actually had
pockets or anything back then but you
could have it with you and it you know
it's it's v it's very short and it's got
a number of
you could call them selections taken
from the longer discourses that aryan
epictetus student who you mentioned
wrote down and then you know selected
bits and pieces of um and so it's sort
of like you know epictetus himself as
far as we know didn't didn't look it
over and say yeah that one should go in
that one should go out but you know if
aryan was a good smart student
presumably this is kind of the best hits
right
right so i don't know if you if you
happen to be watching the video it's
it's literally this is 10 pages in this
book on uh of yeah it's incredibly short
yeah and so like i'm thinking like a
pocket scroll if we want to go to like
what do they have at the time like this
little thing you know so that's an
interesting point so so
there a lot of the ancient literature
you know you see book one book two those
are actually scrolls that would be
unrolled
so
around this time they were starting to
have um what they call la bellum a
little tiny book that's like the books
that we have that that use pages sewn
together into
uh one thing and the end caridian
probably circulated around in both both
formats
you know people would use those um
the bella i guess would be the the uh
proper plural for it and they the stoics
were especially big on you know figuring
out what you'd screwed up in during the
day and how you could improve and
keeping track of things you know what we
call journaling today right and you
would write that down in your little
labellum that you would carry around
with you and so
it could be that that the end creating
was available in two formats
we don't we don't quite know you know
the important thing is that we do have
it and that's what we can actually talk
about you know and we should mention
this
um you can get it dan was referencing a
copy that has the epictetus discourses
and the encrypted and fragments and
probably a nice introduction by the
translators and there's a lot of
different versions out there that you
can buy but you can also find this
incredibly easily online
so
if you're short on money you don't have
you know five or ten bucks to shell out
for
an actual copy
you can have this anywhere you want to
you could read it on your phone
there's all sorts of
formats and translations of it
there's even a website that has uh three
to four different translations side by
side i've seen that that's kind of cool
what so tell me why you like that in
particular um well i don't read greek
and
unlike greg here and so it's useful to
um
see the different ways that the
different translators have translated
this um they
uh kind of you look at like the
the totality of it you can like okay am
i not quite understanding what this um
translator is trying to convey here
maybe someone else says in a little bit
more um understandable uh rockable uh
language yeah i think and i think that's
a great way to use these things
if you find one translation doesn't work
for you it's not like there's anything
wrong with you
um different translations are you know
um
good for one one set of people but not
good for another set of people there's
no like perfect universal translation so
having four of them side by side can be
really handy
yeah
um so i guess what we talked a little
bit about what stoicism is
on what is not socialism so maybe let's
kind of go into some like the really
high end like what what is stoicism it
is a um for the most part we we talk
about it in its ethical system um and i
will often say that um
that socialism is a pro-social
ethical system that uh has a lot of work
in it to try to um help you understand
yourself and you the way that you think
um the way that you
interact with other people and the world
and um and one of the big things that
are usually thrown against doicism is
that this is this
uh
push down and and bottle up your
emotions type thing where in fact it is
very much a
uh
philosophy that tries to get you to
understand your emotions why they happen
in the first place to not to bottle them
but but to um know what they are and to
not allow them to uh
take you along for a ride
yeah and the stoics do say that there
are good emotions so anybody who tries
to say oh stoics they're totally
unemotional they don't they don't
understand stoicism
but you notice that in the way that they
understand good emotions it there's
always
an interconnection between
rationality and
our emotional
side so you know this is this isn't one
of the practices that we want to talk
about here yet but this is a good
example
should you feel fear right fear is a bad
emotion for the stoics in general
there's a lot of different kinds of fear
but there also is
feeling fear in a rational way which
they they call in greek ula baya which
means caution being being cautious or
careful about stuff so you know you
shouldn't
you shouldn't just do anything
whatsoever to show what a tough guy you
are that's not being
stoic there are some things you really
should fear if somebody's like hey poke
this needle in your eye
you should be afraid of that
like you shouldn't be afraid of the dark
but if you have kids that have legos
then you should be very cautious about
walking in the dark that's a great
example yeah i like that one
somebody was proposing recently there
should be like a room just full of legos
and i was like well you know that sounds
really great from a building perspective
but now imagine trying to walk through
that in the dark
yeah no no thank you although like if
you have enough of them is it kind of
like one of those needle beds where the
the
oh the pain is uh divided up in such a
great amount that i mean
maybe but that sounds like a great
experiment for somebody else to try not
not me i agree let someone else
so
um we're going to talk about
philosophical practices and if you
haven't heard that term before that's
that's quite fine there are other
synonyms that get used for that
sometimes they're called spiritual
exercises that's the terminology that
this guy pura do particularly uses um
michel foucault
has this wonderful phrase technologies
of the self and there's there's a lot of
other ways that these are
talked about but the basic idea is
they're things that you
choose to do so there's a deliberate
aspect to it and you don't just do them
once you do them perhaps in particular
situations or you do them before you get
into situations like a daily thing and
if you keep on doing them
they
improve your life they they change the
way you think about things they change
your emotional reactions they change uh
your habits and assumptions and
eventually lead you towards a happier
more tranquil and more
free life
right um and so
i want to enter into this uh
discussion the idea of praxis which is
a practice that is informed by
theory
and one of the things that um we find
with this these practices that we are
talking about is that the the more you
do them um the more they become
ingrained and so it reduces your
reaction time to you know becoming angry
or something in one thing and so that
uh you now having this new
uh way that you've trained yourself
through this practice allows you to
understand a little bit better what the
actual theory behind this was in the
first place which allows you to do the
practice a little bit better thereafter
yeah that's a really good point it's not
there you know we like to say they're
not cookie cutter menu things or bullet
points or life hacks where you you can
get the totality of it
just within you know a day or something
there's a dialectic here the more that
you do it the more that you're actually
doing action and practice and habit and
stuff like that the more the theoretical
explanation of it or as we're going to
talk about some of these you know
passages from epictetus the more sense
they make and it's not as if the sense
wasn't there all the time it's just you
know we often don't we don't grasp these
things right away and that's and that's
perfectly normal
yeah we don't have the experience and so
like i don't know
um
what it is to the feeling of skydiving i
have an idea of what it is and what it
entails
nor do i because
that that ain't gonna happen i've got a
fear of heights you know
and
uh you know
this is a bit off topic but i used to
play minecraft with my kids
and in minecraft it's um you know the
graphics are not great but it's enough
that
i could get vertigo being on top of a
high place and like looking down you
know i could feel like that sense
inside me of uh the fear of uh falling
off but every once in a while i would
and then of course you know your
character dies and you get to go back
and get all their stuff but in real life
you know you fall off a high place or
you know
skydive off a high place and then you're
just there in the air
that
that's definitely an experience
and imagining it for me is already
enough for me to say no no i'm not going
to do that
who knows maybe if i actually did do it
it wouldn't be quite so bad
on in real life yeah
who knows like doing those uh jumps are
rather
i don't know it does seem scary to me
but i know people do them all the time
there's i guess a science to it to a
certain extent right um
but uh i and
and if i was going to read a book on
skydiving and the techniques therein
um especially of like moving one's body
in order to you know uh move through
space in a different way to do summer
assaults yeah yeah what all these things
i i can read about them but doing them
is going to allow me to really
understand what they're saying much more
than uh just kind of like creating a uh
idea in my mind's eye
yeah that's that's a great example i
mean you could say the same thing about
like
martial arts you can get these picture
books that show you all sorts of moves
and stuff like that but until you're
actually like doing the stuff
you don't know
i mean the pictures look cool but you
don't know what's actually going on and
how to move your body in the right way
so that's that's a great metaphor for
what we're what we're doing
in um
spiritual exercises or philosophical
practices however you want to call them
so let's jump right into the the first
one
one of the
really foundational practices and ideas
in stoicism comes from epictetus and
caridian and it comes from chapter one
we call it the dichotomy of control
which is not his term
but it is uh it's a good descriptor so
here's a passage from chapter one he
says some things are under our control
while others are not under our control
under our control are conception choice
desire aversion and in a word
everything that is our own doing
not under our control are
our body our property reputation office
and in a word everything that is not our
own doing so he's making a distinction
there and now here's where the practice
comes in
remember therefore that if what is
naturally slavish you think to be free
and what is not your own to be your own
you will be hampered you will grieve you
will be in turmoil and you will blame
both gods and human beings
while if you think only what is your own
to be your own and what is not your own
to be as it really is not your own
no one will ever be able to exert
compulsion on you no one will hinder you
you will blame no one you will find
fault with no one you will do absolutely
nothing against your will you have no
personal enemy no one will harm you for
neither is there any harm that can touch
you and so
this may sound kind of paradoxical to a
lot of people especially the thing like
your body isn't on your under your
control well we'll talk about that in a
minute but epictetus is saying there's
things that you
you can completely determine and then
there's other things that
get determined by factors outside of you
you know so it could be other people
it could be you know the environment it
could also be inside of you and it could
be like the screwed up things that you
learn from
school or your parents or your your dumb
friends or you know the culture
pick whatever or your own your own
bone-headed uh uh inferences from what's
happened in your life right
but epictetus is saying um you actually
have a lot more control over the things
that are within that sphere
uh then you you credit yourself for and
then the other stuff you you don't
actually have control over it so if we
apply this and that's the practice
remember he says and whenever somebody
like epictetus says remember keep keep
at hand be ready to say
there you've got a
practice so we can start
you know shifting ourselves and it takes
time from being so invested in the
things that are not in our control or or
we can you know we can still be
connected to them but
if we say to our to ourselves hey that's
not in my control
then we're not going to get so upset
about it like for example i i've had
covet lately right
totally out of my control i i got caught
up in that big wave of people who
got the vaccinations were careful about
things wore masks you know at the right
time and all that and you know i thought
i had allergies and boom it turns out i
have covet right and you know it was
like a lot of people i mean very
fortunate it was this milder omicron
thing that doesn't like you know destroy
your lungs or destroy your brain
at least in most cases
and it sucked and you know we had to
isolate here that's no fun
and i'm still you know feeling some
effects of it i i don't have control
over that what i do have control over
is how i think about it
what i
do in relation to it do i say oh
this is the end of the world you know or
do i deny that i have it oh i can't
possibly have covid i'm vaccinated you
know
you know these these are all things that
are up to me and
so being prudent
and what we do with with what is up to
us that's a really really central part
of this
practice i mean what do you want to add
to this this one dan one of the things
that i usually like to add just
especially for someone that's new to
this is those things that are
entirely totally up to us um because
people are just like oh well i have
uh influence over this person i can go
and talk to them
and
and and get them to do what i want but
um
you have control over
talking to them
you don't have any control over
the the all the other things that
they're thinking about and what they're
actually going to do
at any point could decide that you know
you're full of it and they don't want to
do the thing that you want to do
and this is the
the point that we all live in this world
in which the vast majority of the things
that we do
have it one component of things that is
totally under our control and one
component of things that are not under
our control and it's the the size of
these two things that will eventually
determine our outcome if there are you
know um
say uh i want to um influence nasa but
i'm not in nasa and i'm not a
rocket scientist
i can go out and like
wave a sign
outside of nasa or outside of congress
to try to influence them but
by action i have control over like at
least moving towards that action yeah
yeah
there's so many other factors out here
that are going to be overriding that
that my influence is going to be nil and
so like here's my action i have control
over my action
but doesn't mean that the outcome is
going to change because of on me
focusing on that
yeah i mean we can apply that to so many
things where we think if i do this like
if i push this button then this thing
over here or will happen and human
beings aren't like that i mean we do
know how to push each other's buttons in
the sense of like take each other off
but even that might not work you know
maybe the person if you're stoic
well i'm thinking like if the other
person is becoming
not necessarily stoic but at least
better you know
better at managing their emotions
um maybe you poking them isn't going to
provoke what you you want but i mean
people get this mixed up all the time
and so this is something where we would
have to
continually remind ourselves
in real life situations and maybe also
before we get into situations so we're
not
letting our expectations or as epictetus
would say our desire
run away
with us so we don't end up getting upset
as a result
right
um
we've got uh so i guess maybe some of
the other things um
on
the the issues that people will have are
the the focusing
only on
on the individual things that you can do
and and kind of like a screwing or are
dismissing everything else outside of
oneself
yeah there's a tendency
sometimes when people read this to think
oh i should like totally withdrawal from
withdraw myself from all of reality
including other people epictetus isn't
saying that
um
i mean as you pointed out stoicism is a
pro-social
uh philosophy and epictetus is really
big on like fulfilling the roles that
we've undertaken so like you know i
don't get to say to my wife um if i'm
doing something that is annoying her oh
that's totally outside of the sphere of
my control honey you know
epictetus would say no no no you're
screwing up there buddy um you're
misunderstanding it
you know another thing too is sometimes
people will say yeah but i don't really
control my thoughts you know i have
intrusive thoughts that happen i don't i
don't control my emotions the way
epictetus seems to be saying that you do
i can't control what i desire or am a
verse to but we can like bump it up a
level and say okay yeah that's probably
true like you know at least when you're
starting out you're going to have things
that you you might obsess about but you
get to decide
how much you obsess about it and what
you do in relation to that obsessing do
you just give in to it or do you say
this isn't good for me i need to like do
something about this you know
and so this comes down to one of these
other things we were talking about in
what just under our control
are our desires and we we
are obviously you know bombarded with
you know parts of our brains is hey get
that get that
um and and some things are definitely
good to like pursue like you know food
and water probably good things to
regularly pursue
on the few you know especially if you
want to continue living um but they're
um we do have the ability to look at
these desires as they arise in us
and say are these things that are
something i actually want to desire if
i'm looking at this through kind of a
rational lens what are the uh
conclusions of me wanting to desire
these things and
as we'll get into a little bit more
about like this this difference between
what is actually good
um and stoicism says the things that are
good or not
you know things like these all these
things that are indifference here are
our health externals
our
uh wealth our privilege um you know
reputation
all these things um and
if you are desiring these things over
being a good person then there is an
issue there
yeah that's a great point and i think
realizing
that the feelings or desires that we
have are not just like stuff that we're
subjected to and we can't do anything
about but we
we have some say in it
that's incredibly liberating and
powerful and i think not enough people
get that message they're told you're
responsible for your desires and that's
why you're the you know terrible person
you are but they're not told hey you can
actually
not like by snapping your fingers but
you can go in under the hood and monkey
around with the the mechanics of things
and change them over time you know
that's
quite helpful well let's talk about the
next one um why don't you
lead us into this one because this is
one that that that you picked out dan
yes this is a loving fate or a morphati
um so do not ask things to happen as you
wish but wish them to happen
as they do happen and your life will go
smoothly
and so this is another way of saying um
you know uh
happiness is
uh
reality or
expect was it reality minus expectations
okay yeah or
rolling with the punches right yeah
so um we've got this idea here that um
once that there are disturbing things
that we are disturbed by the
the incongruity or like the the
mismatching between what we want and
what is in the world and so like
i can
want a um a ferrari outside
um
but
doesn't mean that it's going to be out
there and if i want it and it's not out
there then i'm upset that it's not out
there you know ah i have to have my
ferrari you know like it's um
i just got a toyota so like um
which is a fine car but i'd also be like
because ferrari decals or something yeah
but i i was thinking more along the
lines of if someone happens to steal my
car
and i go outside and i see my cars there
and i'm
wanting my car to be there i'm going to
be disturbed i'm going that's going to
probably elicit anger
on uh in the fact that the car is not
there anymore and
uh especially because you're like yo
you're gonna run through a thousand
different things oh that means i can't
do this and i have to do this and i have
to call the police and i have to you
know all these things are maybe you got
towed and all these things that you're
like ah i don't want to do
um
but if you're like okay
i can sit here and say
i could really really desire this and
i'm gonna get angry at that
instead you're like okay the car is not
there
what does one do next what does a
um an excellent person in this situation
do do they yell and ramp and rave and
they get angry at their their friends
and their loved ones because this thing
happened or they like okay
here are the things that i need to do to
either get my car back or to call my
insurance or what all these things and
and maintain this this calmness that is
in that person for that yeah
you know i think this so
there's all those like things that we
find
blows you know or
um challenges however we want to put
them right there we want things to be
this way and they're the opposite you
want your car to be there it's gone
right um
you want to be healthy you're sick right
and then there's all sorts of other
cases i think you could apply this to
where it's you know there's the
proverbial fly in the ointment like when
you go to a concert
you know you've you've got your tickets
you're like oh i'm going to see this
band so great example um for my birthday
weekend
uh my wife bought duran duran tickets
and i'm you know i'm a big metal head
but duran duran has been like my one of
my you know secret loves since i was
a kid you know
love their music uh and it's it's great
stuff and i'm i'm really looking forward
to it now what happens at concerts you
know i mean you're not going to be
having the ideal perfect concert
experience uh with in the case of simon
lebon he's not going to be like pointing
out at the crowd at you
singing directly to you
you know and people are gonna like get
in the way they're gonna stand up and
have their cell phones like hanging up
and be videoing it there's gonna be some
jerks who are like drunk or high or
whatever and they're going to like
they're going to get up to get another
beer every so often and
then there's going to be some people
like having conversations on the side
and chatting
and you know maybe maybe not everybody's
you know
got the best personal hygiene and it
stinks a bit or pic pick whatever you
want right there's always going to be
these things or you sit in the seats and
they're not all that comfortable
so you know you can you can say well
what is it that i
was looking for here i'm looking to go
to a concert and this is what concerts
are like you know
i don't have to allow these things to
ruin my night i can still hear the band
and you know what if the band is out of
tune well you know that happens
i i've gone to concerts where the the
lead singer was drunk and forgot the
words and it's like well
he's a rock star what are you expecting
like these are the things that happened
at rock shows
yeah it's quite true yeah
um so yeah like what is
what are you expecting to you know this
is um what expectations are you bringing
to it right and
uh there's a another um kind of idea is
to live the life um
every day as if it's a festival and you
go to a big festival with lots of people
expecting to get bumped into to you know
instead of getting angry at these things
okay well
at a festival these are the things that
happen and if you can say like
in all times that you should say like
okay well things are going to happen and
that's just the way things are it's okay
and it's how you react to these things
that's the more important thing then
we're starting to uh love fate in in
every moment around us
you know i was just thinking uh because
that epictetus uses that that metaphor
of the festival and you know at the
festival not everybody's gonna like want
to talk philosophy maybe through their
stare to gonna have a good time and i
was thinking
you know i think my mind wandered a
little bit i was thinking about so i've
been teaching now
i've been teaching since 1999 college
classes
and
you know you design a class
at before the semester begins it never
ever turns out the way you think it's
going to go in any given class session
some students are paying attention some
of the time some other art and they ask
you you know questions that show that
they're not 100 on anybody who's seen my
videos will well you know that were
recorded in classes can see that and if
you let yourself get bent out of shape
over that and there's a lot of people
who teach who do
you know it's got to stay to the lesson
plan well
you know you're kind of setting yourself
up for being unhappy um
it's it's not reasonable it's it's uh
kind of silly
right um
so another uh things that like similar
to one of the the issues that we brought
up with the our last practice of the
dichotomy of control is this idea of
this kind of like potential nihilistic
trap if you're like okay
um
one it's outside of my control so i'm
not going to use you know yeah yeah
step away from it doesn't matter i'm
also like loving fate and it's like okay
well
um
the the first point is that you need to
love the the thing that you are instead
of having un uh reasonable expectations
of the world around you
um but if you go into this too hard to
just like well i'm gonna love exactly
what is um then you you do nothing like
that there has to be another thing that
goes beyond that you this loving fate
gets you a point of um ex uh
to fully accept the reality of the
situation
and then
the the point after that is to actually
take action of what
what as we call in uh stoicism virtue
otherwise translates as excellent action
for a human with your role um in that
place of time what are you going to
actually do so you're saying it would be
a mistake to take this as like the one
single
practice for stoicism right it's it's a
a practice that has to be fitted in with
other ones
um and since we are talking about
epictetus maybe i'll have a slight aside
to his pedagogical um
uh
workings of the uh disciplines that he
has he has the display of a sense the
discipline of action and the discipline
of
desire desire thank you um and so we
we already talked a little bit about um
uh desire first with the
uh
dichotomy of control what what are the
things that are actually valuable um
we use the dichotomy control to help us
figure out what things are actually
valuable
we assent to the reality of the
situation by you know
figuring out tools that allow us to
understand the world well
um and one of these things is i'm
looking at the world through a
um
to to love life or to love fate to see
the world as it is and not uh with like
a rose-colored wouldn't be great if i
had this type of way on it and then and
then the last part and they they you
know talk about this as like a tripod
that without all three parts that would
not stand
is that there's also that portion of
action what do you do next with this
information with these right judgments
and uh having a really good
understanding of the world around you
now
um
you are involved in startup culture and
that seems like something where i mean
that the dichotomy of control seems to
be
something that would be very helpful in
that because there's so few things that
are actually in your control and yet
there's so many things that you do need
to do
what about um
loving your your fate does that fit in
with it i mean wouldn't it introduce a
kind of passivity where you're like well
i mean maybe investors will invest maybe
they won't it wouldn't do that would it
well it's a little bit of that that
nihilistic trap um but you know this is
actually um absolutely like only uh you
know one in 20 or about five percent of
startups actually make it to the point
where there is either
that's right become becomes a going
thing or um
they get acquired and um this is
actually something that's really useful
because you have such low on probability
that it's going to actually happen in
the long run that's it's like okay well
now what um
i
it failed
i worked as hard as i could my i have my
action i realized that there's a small
amount of insurance i'm trying to do
this thing there is you know people out
there are trying to help you to do these
things um people are counting on you to
do these things and you do them as well
as you can but once again you know there
are so many things outside my control
okay accept that
and if it does fail even though
especially because there's such a high
chance of it failing yeah say
you know
those things happen that is okay
what did i learn from this what can i do
next
it occurs to me that this would apply
really well to um being a fan of a
sports team
you know particularly i mean it could be
college it could be professional it
could be amateur whatever so just think
about the nfl right
um i mean unless you're like a fair
weather fan like all the people who were
cowboys fans here in wisconsin in the
1980s when the cowboys were hot you know
you're probably a packers fan
and the packers have been pretty decent
for
you know
a decade and a half maybe maybe two
decades with the farv and the
rogers era
but you know that's going to come to an
end eventually um we don't have any
great you know new quarterback uh ready
to step in
and there's always problems and you know
i grew up in in the 70s and the 80s when
the packers they did have a few winning
seasons but mostly they were just
terrible
you know and you could say well um
i want my team to
go to the super bowl and and win the
super bowl and well you can desire that
all you want but
you know there's a lot of teams in the
league
the odds of your team any given year
unless we're talking about like you know
when the patriots were dominating
everything year after year after year
which is kind of a weird fluke
um the odds are pretty low you know it's
sort of like
a startup except of course
there's a hell of a lot less work
involved in being a sports fan than
there is and being involved
right you can just sit sit back on your
butt and watch the tv and you know yeah
i'll let the yell at the screen every
once in a while
but
yeah once again you said you know
there's one in 32 teams you know there's
obviously a greater like
[Laughter]
movement going on there and a whole
bunch of other places but uh maybe um
here's another little quote to
a kind of wetter whistle here um so day
by day you must keep before your eyes
death and exile and everything that
seems terrible
but death above all and then you will
never have any abject thought or desire
anything beyond
do
measure so how does that how does that
fit in with a more fatty or love of fate
um so this is i guess a little bit of
pulling into like this pre-meditative
malorum or thinking about bad things
before they happen but especially like
it's it's trying to get you to
love the the reality of things like you
you can
um
you know uh death and exile and anything
that you think is terrible can come at
you at any point in time and if you
are not afraid of these things it
becomes a lot easier for you to
um desire the things that are because
you think okay these things aren't
actually bad
in and of themselves it's only how we're
reacting to them and allow us to more
easily accept the reality of them
that is a good segue into our next
practice
depersonalizing problems so i mean if
you have a hard time thinking about
the death of those close to you as being
something that you know is
is definitely not to be preferred but it
is indifferent then this might be
helpful so epictetus says this is in
chapter 26
what the will of nature is may be
learned from a consideration of the
points in which we do not differ from
each other for example when somebody
else's servant breaks the drinking cup
you're instantly ready to say
well that's one of the things that
happened
rest assured then when your own drinking
cup gets broken you ought to behave in
the same way that you do when the other
person's cup is broken
now apply the same principle to matters
of greater importance some some other
person's child or spouse has died
nobody would say anything other than
well that's the fate of a human being
when a person's own child dies
immediately the cry is alas woe is me
but we ought to remember how we feel
when we hear of the same misfortune
befalling others so you know what is
epictetus saying here you know realize
that the same logic that you apply to
other people you can apply to yourself
you can take yourself out of the
equation now we do tend to think that
like well but this is my
my feelings
i'm exceptional
but that's a big assumption i mean the
universe doesn't think you're
exceptional right you're just one of i
mean how many there's more than seven
billion people here on the planet now
um that's an awful lot you're just one
little tiny blip and if all the others
you know when these things happen to
them you're like well that's the way it
goes you know
you can apply that just as much to
yourself and so you can you know when
you're experiencing something bad like
oh i i lost a job well what did you say
when other people lost their job you can
remind yourself
about how you what what stance you take
towards that
and then you can you know
apply it to your own
condition and you can also like you can
you can kind of turn it in another way
and say well how would other people look
at what's
happening to me i mean did they take it
as
much to heart as
as i do and i kind of think when you do
this
it helps you to feel
a greater sense of confidence that you
can handle the situation you know
[Music]
i mean it's terrible when when your
child dies
but people
have that happen to them and it doesn't
absolutely destroy them life still goes
on you know
when it's lesser stuff you know if your
drinking cup gets broken you might be
very very attached to your your cup but
hey it's a cup you know
okay i had a um
a roommate who had a dog that uh
destroyed the mortarboard in which i
graduated with oh i was like
i can't get that back it is gone now but
it was only ever you know some cloth and
some cardboard and some elastic
um in the first place and
yeah yeah
it's okay you know it
like i still had the memories i still
got photos it definitely got that uh
diploma
going anywhere um so like
at first it was like i was upset and now
i'm like okay well it was just once it
is the thing that happened um and if
this happened to someone else um i
probably would have been easier for me
to say at least you know
depending on
the my relationship with that person
um
on how i'd react to them but i would
probably make the judgment like oh well
it's it's just a thing uh yeah and so
epictetus even says here on
in another part of the the enchiridion
that um you know see someone
you know
just in despair over
on the loss of their child on
go and be a human and and like can uh
comfort this person
um that's that is fine be the human like
if they're they're not a stoic it's fine
you don't need to go like oh well you
should you know uh not feel anything
you're just yeah that's a terrible thing
to do you know to expect other people to
be stoics i think is non-stoic
right um but he says like you know just
don't despair yourself inwardly you can
you can you can be with him and help him
out but don't don't also
try to gain those same things to despair
over something that you know is you know
uh and indifferent
yeah and there's another um really great
passage
that
figures into another aspect of this in
chapter 5 where he says
um
death is nothing dreadful or all
socrates also would have thought so but
the judgment that death is dreadful
that's the dreadful thing
so when we're hindered or disturbed or
grieved let's not blame anyone but
ourselves and that means not like just
blaming ourself like saying oh i'm such
a such an idiot you know but he says
blame our own judgments you know look at
that part of ourself that's giving us
the wrong
take on the situation and the thing with
socrates and the death thing
i mean that can really give you
a way to handle situations you can you
can say well
okay i lost my job that really sucks you
know it's it's not a great economy
but it you know it doesn't have to
destroy my life and make me depressed
because look at how that that person
over there who also lost their job
is handling it there's nothing necessary
about making me
feel depressed or despairing
and then you can say well i still do
feel depressed or despairing and then
you can say
well because it's not necessary there's
got to be something going on in
in your way of looking at it that that
other person's not doing maybe let's
let's look a little bit more closely at
that and then
once you disentangle it maybe you don't
have to be depressed or despairing you
know
um and so a little context here um
if
socrates was uh all right sentence and
um and justly unjustly um
uh put on trial and then uh for
corrupting the youth of the city because
he was out there like
you know talking about like what is
justice and and
why should we like worship the gods and
all these things he's just asking these
things
um
and he's ordered to uh drink hemlock and
so he's even given an option by one of
his friends to break him out of jail
after he's been convicted to say hey you
can go over here i've got a villa you
can go stay at it you can i'll bring you
to the next town you can go and talk to
them and and be the gadfly over there
it's fine i mean it's like no like like
i don't consider this
sentence to be a bad thing i'm i'm
acting virtuously here because i am
upholding um the the values of being a
citizen of athens i'm going to adhere to
the values that i believe in which is
democracy
you know and i think if you look at
socrates death day which we get in
um plato's text the fado
um
he decides to spend it you know doing
philosophy chatting with his friends
consoling them and all that that he's
you know maybe his soul's gonna live on
and there's a point where the jailer who
the guy who has to prepare the hemlock
he's like hey uh listen buddy you
shouldn't be talking so much you know
because that can get your body riled up
and
and uh then i might have to make a
second you know draft of hemlock and
socrates is like
you know i'm gonna die today so i'm
gonna do what i wanna do which is talk
with my friends if you have to prepare a
second
draft of hemlock buddy you can just do
your job that's not anything to me
and so i mean it shows kind of a good
see he's willing to like die but he's
going to die on his own terms he's not
going to be
pushed around by the jailer or something
like that you know he's gonna he's gonna
go out uh in the way that he wants to
and that shows us that that's possible
for us too i mean maybe we won't do that
because we're not all socrates but it
certainly shows that there's nothing
necessary
about um
the stances that we take very often
so we should we should talk about uh i
think we've got time for one more
practice
this is one that you wanted to talk
about i think this is a great one too
yeah this is
um determining the value of a human
and so
from
chapter 44 then kyrian
these arguments do not follow i am
richer than you therefore i am superior
to you i am more eloquent than you
therefore i am superior to you no these
are arguments that follow
i am richer than you therefore my
property is superior to yours
i am more eloquent than you therefore my
style is superior to yours but you
after all are neither property nor style
and so what we have here is you know
once again it comes down to
um part of our discussion earlier with
this dichotomy of control what are the
things that are truly valuable the
things that are truly valuable are
totally up to us
and those are you know our actions our
desires our aversions
and anything that is up to only us
and
well once again like uh the property
here like your wealth your your estate
on your car your horses whatever it
happens to be
are things that are partly not up to
your control and so if you
happen to have them just because you
were gifted them via inheritance
that has no
bearing on like if you even had good
prowess as a businessman but like once
again being good at business has
externals into it and so what we're
really worried about here
is doing good actions to do what the
excellent human would do with the
virtuous action
you know and and epictetus isn't denying
that within their
domain you can't compare things next to
each other like
you know um
for example grades right students get
very obsessed with grades oh i gotta get
an a you know
and
um
you know an a from one professor maybe
isn't actually directly comparable to an
a from another professor even though we
throw them all into the same
big hopper and talk about gpas and stuff
like that which is kind of artificial
but you you know you can compare them
against each other or let's take instead
um
you know how much money is in somebody's
bank account you can look at a bank
account that's got a thousand dollars in
it and you can look at one that's got 10
million dollars in it you can say well
that 10 million dollar bank account is
certainly you know many times the
magnitude of the of the one thousand
dollars it is superior
in the way of being money but that
doesn't mean anything about superiority
per se it doesn't translate into being a
better person it doesn't translate it
doesn't even translate into like being
healthier i mean you can have a 10
million bucks and you know your body's
in terrible shape all these are
different
domains as a matter of fact that reminds
me of something that was kind of kind of
funny in the music industry
there were all these um rich guys
and it was mostly guys a while back that
artificially inflated the market for
electric guitars because they were all
these um you know business types
basically or you know doctors or lawyers
who'd made made plenty of money
and
they
they you know they would buy
um
high-end guitars which then jack the
price way up right
out of the range of a lot of good
practicing musicians
and you you can have the the great
guitar but
unless you've actually put in the time
and practice and have some musical
talent and have a good year you're still
going to suck i mean right you can play
uh stairway to heaven all you want or
smoke on the water but you know that's
not going to get you the you know some
some other songs
and
you're not going to be a good musician
even if you spend lots and lots of money
on your your gear you'll just be a guy
with lots and lots of cool gear that
probably should be in the hands of
somebody who could actually
make use of it you know and i think we
can apply this to just about anything
you know
right
and
herein
we have you know what are the things
that
um
you can use these things like yeah say
we have money or wealth or health here
on you know if you are a
person making good actions doing like
the uh the ethically good decision um
having these externals like this extra
wealth will allow you to potentially do
more but in the opposite if you are
someone that is you know vicious and
wants to uh hurt or put down or or
oppress someone having these things
makes it easier for them to do these
things it's kind of a magnifier
if you're familiar with um
oh vector math it's like you have uh
and this is the the magnitude of this
thing not the the vector
okay
the vector is where it's going right um
for for our listeners yes we've got a
unit vector that is you know a value of
one it has a direction and it's um but
then the magnitude is applied to it so
you've got a lot of money it can make
the good thing really good or a bad
thing really bad and so yeah they'll
they'll talk about um
the a tyrant if you have a ruler who is
a tyrant um usually you consider health
to be a good like a universal good
people like that guy to get sick and die
right
yeah yeah and there's there's another uh
passage that you picked out that's
connected
to this chapter 6 don't be elated at any
excellence which is not your own if a
horse
should say i'm beautiful it would be
bearable but when you
get elated and you say i have a
beautiful horse know that you're elated
about what in fact is only the good of
the horse
what is your own good the use of
impressions or
in in greek fontasia so when you behave
consistently with nature and the use of
these you should be happy you should be
elated for you will be elated about some
good of your own and this goes to you
know we could talk about virtue in this
case do you have any virtues if so be
happy but if not well then maybe you
shouldn't be so happy and and you see
people getting you know oh man i've got
the the newest game console or i've got
the high-end uh tequila or i mean we can
come up with a million i've got this
this you know
really attractive spouse or boyfriend or
girlfriend or i went to harvard or you
know
anything you want you can you can like
say you can brag about it right
but whatever excellence that has it
doesn't translate to you automatically i
mean i've met a lot of kind of duds from
ivy league schools myself
um i know that the distribution of like
really smart people to really dumb
people it's basically about the same
anywhere you go you know
so those
dang bell curves on so
i think anything else to say about this
one before we we start wrapping up
um the only thing that i could say is
like sometimes people misattribute um
the the virtue uh on two things
themselves and so oh like yo with it
with we usually just uh translate virtue
as excellence and so they're like okay
well what what is an excellent road or
what is an excellent horse or something
along those lines um and then we're
trying to talk about this in the virtue
sense but like these things are still
outside of our own control and uh what
we're really worried about is the the
excellence of the
human here and
so
do you want to lead us out on some
thoughts so we have our final thoughts
here
by
uh stoke philosopher
epictetus
if someone handed over your body to
anyone he met along the way
you would be angry
but are you not ashamed that you hand
over your judgment to anyone who happens
to come along
[Music]
you